>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
ONE OF THE MOST
BEWILDERRERRING MOMENTS HOW
QUICKLY MOVES.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" HIT
PIECE ON BRETT KAVANAUGH.
BRAND NEW ACCUSATION OF
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT BUT THEN
LATER HAD TO ADMIT THAT IT
WAS ALL A SHAM.
WHEN DID THAT HAPPEN?
FEELS LIKE A YEAR AGO.
ACTUALLY, NO, IT WAS JUST
LAST WEEK.
THAT IS THE TRUMP ERA NEWS
CYCLE FOUR.
SCANDALS THAT USED TO GO ON
FOR MONTHS NOW SEEM TO END
IN HOURS.
NOTHING ILLUSTRATES THAT
BETTER THAN THIS BIZARRE
UKRAINE STORY THAT WE ARE
ALL LIVING THROUGH.
A WEEK AGO NO ONE EVEN HEARD
OF IT.
LAST NIGHT WE ARE ON THE
BRINK OF IMPEACHMENT BECAUSE
OF IT AND NOW IT SEEMS TO BE
OVER ALREADY.
JUST TO BRING YOU BACK AND
REMIND YOU WHAT JUST
HAPPENED.
THE SAME ANGRY NEWS ANCHORS
WHO BROUGHT YOU STORMY
DANIELS AND THE RUSSIA HOAX
NOW WANT YOU TO KNOW BIG
ORANGE'S DAYS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE WERE FINALLY OVER.
WHY?
BECAUSE TRUMP, THEY SAID,
THREATENED TO WITHHOLD
MILITARY AID TO UKRAINE.
ESSENTIAL MILITARY TIED
UKRAINE FOR SOME REASON.
WITHHOLD IT UNLESS THEY DID
SOMETHING BAD TO JOE BIDEN
AND HIS FAMILY.
BASICALLY IT WAS AN
EXTORTION PLOT AGAINST
UKRAINE.
AND THAT'S A CRIME, THE NEWS
ANCHORED SHOUTED.
A CRIME, TRUMP WAS FINISHED.
WELL, THIS MORNING THEY
TURNED OUT TO BE WRONG.
ACTUAL EVIDENCE EMERGED AND
IT CONTRADICTED WHAT THEY
TOLD US YESTERDAY.
THE ADMINISTRATION RELEASED
A TRANSCRIPT OF THE
PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALL WITH
THE UKRAINIAN HEAD OF STATE
AND IT SAYS NONE OF THE
THINGS THE NEWS ANCHORS
CLAIMED IT WOULD SHOW.
READ IT FOR YOURSELF.
DON'T TRUST US.
IT'S RIGHT ONLINE.
TRY TO FIND THE EXTORTION IN
THERE.
THERE ISN'T ANY.
TRUMP NEVER EVEN MENTIONS
MILITARY AID YES, BUT HE
ASKED A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT
TO INVESTIGATE AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN AND THAT'S IMMORAL.
OKAY.
WAS IT IMMORAL WHEN THREE
DEMOCRATIC SENATORS WROTE A
LETTER TO UKRAINE JUST LAST
YEAR DEMANDING
INVESTIGATIONS INTO TRUMP?
NO ANSWER ON THAT QUESTION
REALLY.
WE WILL TELL YOU IF WE HEAR
ABOUT.
INSTEAD NOW THEY ARE TELLING
US THAT THE TRANSCRIPT OF
THE PHONE CALL CAN'T BE
REAL.
IT MUST BE DOCTORED.
WATCH CHUCK SCHUMER AND ADAM
SCHIFF SPIN THEIR CONSPIRACY
THEORY LAST NIGHT.
>> DO YOU TRUST THE WHITE
HOUSE ENOUGH TO TAKE THAT
TRANSCRIPT AND BELIEVE THAT
THAT IS AN ACTUAL
REPRESENTATION OF WHAT
TRANSPIRED?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I THINK
SADLY IT'S THE CASE AS YOU
DESCRIBE THAT WE CANNOT
TRUST THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH RESPECT TO ANYTHING
THAT IT PRODUCES.
>> SIMPLY TO RELEASE THE
TRANSCRIPT IS NOT GOING TO
COME CLOSE TO ENDING THE
NEED OF THE AMERICAN PUBLIC
AND THE CONGRESS TO SEE WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: SO, AGAIN, THAT
WAS LAST NIGHT BEFORE THE
TRANSCRIPT WAS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE.
NOW THAT IT IS PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE FOR ADAM SCHIFF'S
CONSPIRACY ALLEGED BRAIN HAS
LURCHED INTO A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION.
NOW HE IS TELLING US THAT
THE TRANSCRIPT, THE ONE THAT
HE HAS ALREADY DENOUNCED AS
FAKE IS, IN FACT, REAL.
BUT IT DOESN'T SHOW WHAT IT
SHOULD SHOW, WHICH IS TO SAY
IT DOESN'T SHOW THE
PRESIDENT DOING ANY OF THE
THINGS THAT SUPPOSEDLY
JUSTIFY IMPEACHMENT.
WHY?
WELL, ADAM SCHIFF EXPLAINS,
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT, LIKE
A NAVAJO CODE TALKER IS
SPEAKING IN SECRET CODE.
>> THIS IS HOW A MAFIA BOSS
TALKS.
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE FOR US?
WE HAVE DONE SO MUCH FOR
YOU.
BUT THERE IS NOT MUCH
RECIPROCITY.
I HAVE A FAVOR I WANT TO ASK
YOU.
WHAT IS THAT FAVOR?
OF COURSE THE FAVOR IS TO
INVESTIGATE HIS POLITICAL
RIVAL, A CLASSIC MAFIA-LIKE
SHAKEDOWN OF A FOREIGN
LEADER.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW, WE ARE
NOT PSYCHIATRISTS HERE BUT
HONESTLY ADAM SCHIFF IS A
NUT CASE.
IT'S TRUE.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE HE IS
IN CONGRESS.
POOR PEOPLE OF ANAHEIM OR
WHEREVER HE IS FROM.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, THE
VALLEY SOMEWHERE.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE HE IS
ACTUALLY IN CONGRESS.
HE IS ACTUALLY A COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
TOO BAD THE 25TH AMENDMENT
DOESN'T APPLY TO MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
TO BE FAIR, MOST DEMOCRATS
ARE NOWHERE AS NEAR AS CRAZY
AS ADAM SCHIFF, NOT EVEN THE
SAME BALL PARK.
THEY ARE JUST VERY CYNICAL,
EXTREMELY CYNICAL.
MORE CYNICAL THAN YOU HAVE
EVER THOUGHT OF BEING.
FOR EXAMPLE, WATCH
CONGRESSMAN AL GREEN WHO IS
NOT STUPID OR CRAZY EXPLAIN
WHAT'S ACTUALLY DRIVING
IMPEACHMENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT
IMPEACHMENT TALK MAY
ACTUALLY HELP THE
PRESIDENT'S RE-ELECTION?
>> I'M CONCERNED THAT IF WE
DON'T IMPEACH THIS PRESIDENT
HE WILL GET REELECTED.
>> Tucker: I'M CONCERNED IF
WE DON'T IMPEACH HIM HE WILL
GET REELECTED.
I'M CONCERNED THAT DEMOCRACY
COULD HAPPEN.
WE HAVE GOT TO STOP THAT.
IT'S ABOUT POWER.
DUH.
YOU KNEW THAT.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS ALWAYS
ABOUT, POWER.
NOBODY PUSHING FOR
IMPEACHMENT ACTUALLY CARES
ABOUT SECRET DEALS WITH
FOREIGN LEADERS.
OH, PLEASE.
MUCH LESS JUSTICE OR THE
TRUTH.
AGAIN, THESE ARE THE MOST
CYNICAL PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT AND YOU
KNEW THIS ALREADY WAS
WINNING THE 2020
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THAT'S ALL THEY CARE ABOUT.
GETTING THEIR MITTS ON THE
LEVERS OF POWER AND
EXERCISING POWER FOR ITS OWN
SAKE.
THAT'S WHAT DRIVES THEM.
THAT'S WHY THEY GET UP IN
THE MORNING.
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS HAVE
DECIDED THAT IMPEACHING
TRUMP ESSENTIAL IF THEY ARE
GOING TO WIN NEXT YEAR.
SO THEY ARE STAKING
EVERYTHING ON THIS BIZARRE
FLIMSY SCANDAL THAT THE REST
OF US CAN BARELY EVEN
UNDERSTAND.
WILL IT WORK?
PROBABLY NOT.
PERSONAL ATTACKS ON TRUMP
WERE EFFECTIVE, IF CALLING
HIM A RACIST OR A TRADER
ACTUALLY WORKED, THEN
HILLARY CLINTON WOULD BE
RUNNING FOR RE-ELECTION
RIGHT ABOUT NOW.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK.
IT'S NEVER WORKED.
IF YOU WANT TO BEAT TRUMP,
MAKE A CASE ON THE ISSUES.
HE WON ON THE ISSUES.
MAKE A COUNTER CASE.
THE GENIUSES CAN'T FIGURE
THAT OUT.
IN THE END THE LOSER HERE IN
THIS IMPEACHMENT NONSENSE IS
LIKELY TO BE JOE BIDEN.
BIDEN, YOU WILL RECALL, THE
FRONTRUNNER, SUPPOSEDLY.
HE IS SUPPOSED TO BE THE
SAFE CHOICE.
THE GUY WHO IS GOING TO
ENERGIZE THE OBAMA COALITION
AND WIN BACK THE WHITE HOUSE
AND YET NOW DEMOCRATS HAVE
IN EFFECT DEMANDED THAT WE
SPEND THE NEXT SIX MONTHS
TALKING ABOUT BIDEN AND HIS
SON'S ALLEGED CORRUPTION.
BECAUSE THAT'S AT THE CORE
OF THIS UKRAINE STORY.
IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
UKRAINE AND IMPEACHMENT, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT JOE
BIDEN'S CORRUPTION, ALLEGED
CORRUPTION.
THAT CAN'T HELP HIS CAMPAIGN
FOR PRESIDENT.
IN FACT, IT'S LIKELY TO TANK
IT.
IT LOOKS LIKE SABOTAGE,
REALLY.
THEY MUST HAVE GAMED THIS
UP.
THEY MUST KNOW.
IS IT SABOTAGE?
HONESTLY, WE DON'T KNOW.
WE ARE NOT IN THE ROOM.
MAYBE IT IS.
OR, MAYBE DEMOCRATS HAVE
JUST BECOME SO OBSESSED WITH